[Musik]
Boris Johnson über die Brexiteers mit
Sofia Material
Venedig
[Musik] Ich bin
wirklich 20 Jahre lang nicht gefahren, aber ich
denke, für England ist es genug, ja,
wahrscheinlich, ja, der Rechte ist, ja,
und der Linke will aufhören, okay,
du fühlst dich  die freiheit ich fühle freiheit
bereit für diese eine autobahn
[musik]
also warum denkst du dass england
so große probleme hat
lastwagenfahrer zu finden weil sie jahrelang
gelernte fahrer schlecht behandelt
wurden meiner meinung nach okay
schlechte arbeitsbedingungen schlechte plätze
um schlechte
raststätten zu stoppen bist du zufrieden mit boris johnson oder brauchst du
einen neuen premierminister hast du
vorschläge wir haben eine person die
viel zeit hat jetzt heißt er amin
laschette ja gut ja nichts ist
besser als das was wir haben vielleicht so außer
dir  brauchen miss merkel auch nicht können wir sie
nicht nehmen du willst miss merkel ja
warum nicht ja nimm sie sie sie nimmt sie nimm
sie sie ist pensioniert also ja warum nicht
[musik]
in belfast
ist es dir möglich diesen job zu machen
meine ich  ich komme  aus deutschland du wohnst gleich
um die ecke komm schon ja ich
habe keinen führerschein eigentlich hast
du keinen naja ich habe einen vorläufigen
aber
das reicht sie suchen nach
jedem du hast du hast einen
führerschein ich hab ja
das ist okay sie überprüfen das nicht
wirklich
sie tun es nicht sie tun es nicht wirklich nein
mehr du bist ein lastwagenfahrer nein nein nein
nein nein kein fahrer du bist ich habe meinen
fiesta gecrasht ich kann keine laurie fahren  Ich fahre einen
Chef, ja, also weißt du, wie man fährt, ja
, das ist gut, aber ich nehme an, Johnsons
Schuld, lass ihn die verdammten Fahrer
finden, es gibt einen Mann, Boris Johnson, ist seine
Schuld  Für Deutsche
, die gehen und Lastwagen fahren, obwohl sie
vorher noch nie einen Lastwagen gefahren sind, ich
meine, es ist irgendwie durcheinander, wer, glauben Sie
, ist schuld an Boris Johnson, dem
Premierminister oder C Bojo,
es ist alles ein C persönlich, genau das ist
deutsche komödie
ja deutsche kolonie das ist deutsche komödie
man
t  hey lachen
war das lustig yeah yeah warum glaubst du
gibt es jetzt diese probleme in england,
dass es so einen mangel an
fahrern gibt
brexit brexit
yeah weil ich meine ja
yeah es muss ein rockstar sein alles
alles gesichert
[musik]
erinner dich an
die  linke seite zum fahren
linke seite natürlich bin ich kein idiot
[musik]
hey leute ja ja
danke an laurie schaut aus deutschland
[musik]
ausländisch